foreign
good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us today both here in person and
our viewers online at home
this month we this month we have the
karakira first uh and Nikki uh has very
kindly offered
um who is our GM of people and culture
to start us off with the karakia and I
will close the meeting with a prayer
when you're ready Nikki
greetings greetings greetings to you all
let us begin today's meeting with the
karakia timataka this will assist us to
clear our heads and to heart so we can
focus on the essential work for which
we're about to commence as this is a
mindfulness karakia please feel free to
be seated
to cooler to wairua kiriri kiato Mata
foreign
and for anyone else please be seated
do we have any apologies today
looks like everyone's here
fantastic
any Declarations of conflicts of
interest
uh councilor Paul mcphail I just with
desert country I manager a venue in town
which has a country events on it I just
wanted to let everybody know that's what
I don't think it's a conflict but I
thought a bit of Internet
thank you councilor uh Council Reed
thank you I am a trustee of tussock
country so I'm declaring that interest
thank you counselor councilor McKenzie I
do business with tacit country through
advertising Etc and do attend some of
the meetings
thank you counselor
thank you for that counselors moving on
to minutes of the meetings for the
minutes of the ordinary meeting of the
gordash council held on the Tuesday 21st
of March 2023.
did we have any questions for governance
support on these minutes
could I please have a mover that these
minutes are true incorrect uh councilor
Dixon and second to councilor Phillips
any further comment
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
do we have any late urgent business
no thank you counselors
first up we have a presentation from the
New Zealand Country Music Festival trust
I'd like to welcome both Jeffrey and
Julie Mitchell thank you for taking the
time to present to us and letting us ask
some questions uh Jeff if you would like
to come up and and take it away when
you're ready
thank you
uh you worshiped the mayor core District
councilors uh great to be here and thank
you for the opportunity to present in
person this proposal today is uh his
worship
indicated we have Julia Mitchell uh with
me as well from the tussa country trust
board and also an apology from Kerry
McLeod another trust board member who
was unable to make it due to some work
commitments
so this afternoon we'd like to start off
with a with a very short video
maybe just I'm pressing the wrong button
my lovely assistant
[Music]
foreign
Tessa country 2021
just like to put maybe some context
around the The Proposal today the
Bailey's test Academy Music Festival
trust was was formed in 2019 as an
umbrella organization
and the brand Bailey's Chester country
was born
we really run just three events as a
trust ourselves one is top Paddock which
is a youth orientated young persons
orientated country maybe country rock
event in the Town and Country Club
Stadium
the tussa country Ute muster and new for
23 is a tussa country stage most of the
other events
are brands are managed by the partner
organizations that collectively come
under the tussa country umbrella and
obviously we have the Cornerstone event
being the MLT New Zealand gold which are
Awards the country music Club Gold
Country Music Club is a significant
partner in what's happened all the way
back to 1974. so in those almost 50
years
what's happened what was originally
called Queen's birthday weekend now
King's birthday weekend is turned into a
10-day Festival
the Bailey's tusted Country Music
Festival trusts says there are eight uh
wonderful volunteers who uh who organize
this
there's an estimated 544 hours of
volunteer work annually I I hasten to
point out that that's when there's no
Festival as we've only had one out of
our three years of duration we've only
had the one in 2021 when there is a
festival those volunteer hours rank
close to a hundred thousand for pulling
this off
the trust currently holds one paid
position and that's of the the marketing
contractor at a fifty thousand dollar
salary per annum at a 20 hours a week
and the position is currently kindly
paid for by the gore District Council
The Proposal
so the trust is seeking an extension of
funding of the council to continue the
support and growth of of the festival
with financial stability
the extension of the funding on a
sliding scale will continue to support
Bailey's tussa Country Music Festival
until the trust is in a financial
position that we can independently pay
for this role
as I said earlier
with the the pandemic we've only managed
one out of three years that we've
actually run a full Festival
applying conservative growth forecasts
we propose the continued Council support
for additional three years would mean
that the festival would be in a position
to promote and renumerate this role
independently
we thought we would have been there by
now but covert had other ideas
so the sliding scale of council support
would look like this year one
next year 100 sliding year two 75 and
year three fifty percent
to years four and five no council
support required
we're there getting too bogged down on
figures
if we look at year 2024
the cost of the position being fifty two
thousand
the cost to the council would be for
that hundred percent for the first year
of 52 000.
taking the profit estimated profit from
tussock country into the next year and
compounding it councils
would drop their funding to 75 of that
figure to 39 000 and a long further to
touch the Country Music Festival
contribution would be 13.
so as you start paying less we start
paying more and the right hand column
remaining profits we still will be able
to pull this off and be in the black
after 2028.
understanding that they're all
projections
the growth rate of 10 is something that
we think is is doable but there is a lot
of volatility financially in our globe
at the moment
Four Points tussa Country Music Festival
achieves the level of profit that is
forecast
the various long-term grants
sponsorships are maintained and the
current success rate of annual grants is
also maintained
number three
tcmef continues to reach regular
audiences
and new audiences are captured through
digital marketing
number four the maintained Festival
popularity means Landmark events can
potentially have a nominal increase in
ticket price in the future
numbers two and three uh
vital really to the support that we may
have for the role of contract if you go
to the next slides yes
the long-term grass and sponsorships are
maintained and tussock Country continues
to reach the audiences as well as new
audiences that are captured through
digital marketing
and if we go to the next slide they're
very much tied closely to the marketing
contractor's role
without the role the feasibility of the
festival growth would be severely
compromised
short-term Council support of the royal
curator Festival that ultimately employs
and pays their own contractor
so what will this money support
without this funding really the role
can't exist
the current version of Bailey's tussa
Country Music Festival creates
significant economic benefit to the
district
we've only had one it was very
successful and
with surveys done for that 2021 Festival
it's a conservative estimate that we
would have bought 1.7 million into the
economy locally
if we think about the return on
investment the all-important ROI as
people would call it
cancels investment into the event
the return is is very very significant
what would this funding mean to the
district
it would help to ensure the festival
continue
to put National and international
spotlights on gawa as New Zealand's home
of country music
it will enable long-term continuation of
a festival that owns and celebrates the
unique charm
the character the warm Hospitality that
make us who we are
we have created a brand for one of a
Southlands top three events
the other two being WAMU field days and
the boot Monroe challenge
and I think I would also throw into the
mix for Gore the hokanui Fashion Design
Awards
fundamentally we want to give a
community a dynamic exciting Festival
their residents and visitors look
forward to both now and in the future
and I think it's safe to say that in in
the time that tussa country has been
operating
we've started to change perceptions of
what happens at King's birthday weekend
certainly in Years Gone by there's been
a perception that maybe people might
leave town
but it's changing and we're looking at
trying to get people to stay and also
not only be involved but participate
I think the tide is turning as the
perceptions of what Tesla country has
done
it gives the district a second economic
Christmas
and I would like to to point to we all
know the sister city fagoras Tamworth
and most of you will know Tamworth has
had a very successful Country Music
Festival for a very long time
and this is a quote from Barry Harley
which I thought worth bringing to you
today and
the festival does not make a profit for
Council but creates another Christmas
for those in the front line of retailers
accommodation restaurants Etc
and the follow-on for others from The
increased economy throughout the entire
year
in Tamworth the festival's 10 days
equates to 20 of tamworth's annual
economy
which broadly means that more than one
month in some cases two Traders
experienced in those 10 days of the team
with the Country Music Festival
so maybe some questions for us
would be how do we build on the success
how do we fully quantify the festival's
impact on our community and learn more
from other festivals such as Tamworth or
even the art deco Festival in the North
Island
we as a board have been looking at uh
ways to do a better job of quantifying
what actually does come into the
community during the country festival
and and um
looking at the possibility down the line
of of
purchasing leasing software
infrastructure that could help us
exactly quantify what's going on and
understanding too that that may be able
to be utilized for the hokanui Fashion
Design Awards or the burpen row or
others others other events that are here
to to really let us know really what
significant impact these events are
having
thank you for your time today
that's all I need to say any questions
that anybody would like to ask
do our best to answer
thank you very much for that Jeff I
don't know if you wanted Julie to come
up as well or No need no pressure
I find that two people answering
questions is always easier than one
counselors do we have any questions
uh cancel the Stringer
oh thanks guys for turning up and um
that's very informative
[Music]
so for the past three years have been
made to secure ultimate funding for
someone in this 20-year position right
um
have
we um come to a point where we need to
look at Queen listen to say the annual
plan or long-term plan for you guys to
this funding Carol Stream and what
happens after three years say we we
don't get that income coming through to
support that slide and scale effect sure
um I know you guys have got a lot of
reading to do the rest from risk
mitigation and those notes that we sent
you uh councilor um
we are constantly looking for ways to
fund this Festival it's just what we do
you know and I think um
there's a lot of unknowns going forward
even for this year with the financial
climate we find ourselves in nationally
you know so we we do what we can and put
our best foot forward and we'll see what
happens this year
going forward
a significant step this this past I
guess year has been the inclusion of
Bailey's as a naming sponsor for a
three-year period so that's that's been
a huge boost to the festival that's
committed and that's guaranteed for
three years
constantly through the pandemic there
were funds that would pop up from
government that would help events like
us survive and continue
with with the long-term vision of
how long to Envision of sustainability
within our own within our own coffers
absolutely and we would have been there
if we if we can judge the success of
year one we would confidently say that
we will be sustainable within our within
our own ranks if we had three in a row
and I think looking forward we still
feel very very comfortable that that
would be the case
hmm
thank you councilor councilor r
mcfarrell
it's just true you worship for uh Jeff
and Julie thank you very much for a
great presentation obviously highlights
one of the assets that we do get uh here
in Gore just in regard to the increase
the 15 margin that they work on for the
increase each year
where does that come from was it I
didn't read it in the in the report is
it an industry standard because I know
that with a number of events that had
around South London obviously otago they
seem to have a much higher increase than
that there seems to be a great demand
um any discussion where the 15 comes or
could it be it's obviously a moderate or
a lower end figure for the numbers that
you're expecting
or is there a maximum that you'd go to
we've taken 10 as a as a base we've also
run the figures at five percent actually
um growth and it still makes sense for
us as a as an entity to be sustainable
at the end of at the end of that
three-year sliding scale so we think we
think Timber scene is a reasonably sound
conservative growth estimate based on
all the
criteria that we could find but we did
run the figures at five percent as well
and feel comfortable that there could
that could still be achieved yeah
but then I think um if you look on the
figures um if any of I'm sure you all
know
um the festival in 2021 had 31 events
prior to that when we were just running
the gold retire Awards and a few events
around it there were six this year
there's just over 62 events planned for
the town
so we feel quite confident with that
growth
thank you councilor any further
questions
no thank you guys very much we'll we'll
jump into a conversation around the
recommendation
thank you for your time
we would like to pass out uh the
presentations that you've seen today for
you to digest
and also potentially
um if you haven't been to any events
that toss the country feel free to try
and experience that and if necessary we
would be happy to reconvene August
to give you some time to soak up what
really is uh what the event's really
about thank you thank you you wish
can we get a round of applause for the
presentation
[Applause]
thank you very much so the the
recommendation on the table is that the
report be received at the funding
request be considered
um I just had one question before I ask
for a mover and a second uh for staff
there was a comment in the presentation
that the role has been paid for to uh
December 2024 uh no 2023 okay fantastic
so this would be for 2024 2025 and 2026.
fantastic thank you for that
clarification
did we have a mover that that report be
received and that the funding requests
be considered uh councilor Stringer and
seconded by councilor mcphail I will now
open for debate
if there is any
uh councilor Phillips
thank you you worship no it's not a
debate it's just uh congratulations when
I sit around this table I have to be
conscious about the money that we're
spending on ratepayers funds uh it's
limited but I believe that what we're
doing today would be a is a great asset
and it keeps the community well and hard
I think
then if that counselor councilor Dixon
yes I also would like to thank to as a
country for the presentation today
and I'd like to add too that it's a very
good event because it covers all ages
which is really great for Gore young
people can get out there a lot right
through to elderly so yes
congratulations and I I fully support it
thank you
thank you councilor any further comment
around the table
cancer Garden
he's yeah I think a very good
presentation to us all and um no doubt
we've all experienced as a country and
um I think it's something that the
community does
gain from and I think it's one of the
most positive ones I've seen with the
presentation like that when it
disappears in three years
thank you very much
thank you councilor
any further comment from around the
table
no I would I would tend to agree I think
the
the benefits outweigh the costs on this
one and as councilor guider guide I'm
really very well put out
um it's nice to see a someone come to us
with a sliding scale of how they're
going to fund these sorts of roles
themselves so it's it's very impressive
to see there's no further conversation I
will put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried thank you
councilors
next up we have the notice of motion uh
Point number six on page 58 would the
Mover like to talk to the motion thank
you your worship yes I would both by way
of introduction
um to it and providing
um I guess a personal perspective I was
elected to this Council last year as a
first-time counselor I came in with lots
of energy and enthusiasm and I'm proud
to be a counselor and to serve this
community and hold the position of
Deputy mere
my goal was to represent the people and
to make a positive difference to the
day-to-day operations of the council and
I'll continue to do that to the best of
my ability
but hanging over me is a clear cloud of
sadness and of frustration
sadness that we have an empty chair over
here where Brit heisted a counselor who
served many years served this community
extremely well and he will be missed
frustration because of the unrelenting
desire of the press and others to search
out what they see is a good story
my work environment and the environment
of Staff as well I'm sure
is full of distractions and stress
I would much prefer the reporters who
are here today to talk about the good
things that make the gore District what
I consider the best provincial area in
New Zealand
we don't have the extremes of what
happened in the urban larger areas what
we do have for example is a library
that's just been open that is probably
the most modern and Innovative in the
country
we have a museum Edition recently put in
that that looks at the illicit whiskey
that used to be dealt with in the hill
burnt made in the hills and we have our
own still we're the country music
capital of New Zealand and the brown
trout capital as well
a dysfunctional relationship between the
mayor and chief executive is not
sustainable and the detailed content of
a meeting that was closed to the public
appearing in the papers is has
questioned our trust of the people
around us
we as elected representatives must come
to terms with that and we will and will
do that responsibly taking into account
our legal and moral obligations
prior to the meeting of the 28th of
March we were not aware of the state of
the relationship between the mayor and
the chief executive at that meeting of
28 March we took immediate steps to put
in place a person to act as an
intermediary
between the two to help the situation we
recognize that as a short-term step
collectively following that meeting
councilors have determined that there is
more to be done
we don't have amongst ourselves the
necessary skill set to do that the
knowledge
Etc and for that reason looking at
having independent advice from a trained
expert to guide us forward so that we
can work on the things that we should be
focusing on
I have not been involved in a review of
this type in the past I'm not too sure
how long it would take but I would take
the hope that it can be done in a matter
of several months
who will provide that review has not yet
been determined we need to get these
Provisions through Council in the first
place and the exact matters that they
will be looking at need to be dealt with
in terms of a terms of reference
the motion that I have entered into
council with a number of other
counselors endorsing is in three parts
the first part deals with the
appointment of an independent reviewer
to lead us through that process
the second part
is worded so that terms of reference are
then drafted
those exact terms will need to be worked
through I guess collectively and
counselors may wish to discuss how that
is done
the third part is a commitment to the
public and beyond that whatever comes
out of the review is not going to be put
on a shelf unless left to get dust or
put in a drawer but we will act on it it
is a commitment from our part to show
that we are prepared to move forward
responsibly both with regard to our
legal and moral obligations I therefore
move that the three resolutions that are
included in the agenda be put to for
consideration
thank you councilor to over second of
that motion councilor Reed would you
like to speak or
would you like to speak to the motion I
would thank you Mr Mayor um thank you to
the deputy mayor for the
very erudite way he has presented that
in a clear manner as well but personally
myself I believe that I would be failing
in my duty to the oath that I've sworn
three times
if I didn't support and commit to an
independent review so that is called for
in the motion before us I also believe
that counselors the council is sitting
around the table who'll sign the
recommendation in good faith understand
completely their Collective
responsibility to the people of the gore
District
and they are very focused on continuing
sound governance and say that very
slowly so you get my drift
but I'd also like to make comment on the
fact that
another thing that actually is quite a
welcome thing to say the Swift
affirmation of the chief executive and
more recently the mayor to also report
and support this review and I think
that's a very welcome thing so thank you
both
thank you councilor and thank you both
uh for those words
I will now open the floor to any further
comment by councilors on the motion
councilor McKinsey
personally I didn't sign the agreement
at the time I felt I was being rushed a
little bit but I have no objection to it
at all
so I just like to add that comment in
there
thank you
thank you councilor
uh uh councilor rich mcphail
sir three worshiping through to the
deputy mere and councilor uh read there
they've obviously covered off what
the majority of the councilors probably
feel in regard to why we're actually
sitting here today and having to address
this issue we fall back on to the
principles of why we were elected trust
respect honesty
confidence
plus we have to be accountable
and we've been in the position now we
would probably need to be accountable to
our community
I think our principles have probably
been tried
so the fabric of what we base ourselves
on needs to be addressed so I totally
support
the the
um
the review
and also the fact of what the deputy
mayor has said it has to be transparent
doesn't need to be put on a shelf and we
need to show the community that we
actually are a person or persons
that can be trusted to give good sound
and proper governance without risk of
leaks
or other matters happening
that bring our Council into disrepute
thank you councilor any further comment
the the only two comments that I'd have
is is first of all I was never given the
opportunity to sign this nurse emotion
but I am in support of review I think
that we can always do better as a
council and I take on board all the
comments of the councilors here today I
think it's very appropriate that we do
fall back on the reason that we were
elected and make sure that we are
serving the community to the best of our
ability
the only other comment I had and I know
it's been moved and second is
um I just note the recommendation that
the gorgeous Council seek an independent
review
um sorry that the draft of the terms of
reference for the review be prepared for
consideration are we all comfortable
with staff undertaking it role it is a
regular procedure for staff to undertake
that role I know that councilor hoval
mentioned that it would be in
combination do we need to put that in
the recommendation
for a recountable with staff carrying
out that review
councilor Garden
that staff will prepare the terms of
reference but it still is to come to
council for ratification so that'll
happen in May and so we can still debate
the terms of reference
councilor Phillips the user though are
more than comfortable with the staff
making the review to bring to council
thanks
councilors is there any more discussion
on this notice of motion
there is not I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
and against the motion has been carried
thank you councilors
now we have the gore District Council
recycling update uh did the report
writer Jason want to speak to this
report at all
thank you through you worship
um
I just uh I'll take the report as read
the only thing I'll just sort of state
to see this is probably not the report
that councilors were expecting to
receive uh at this meeting the last
meeting we talked about providing costs
and for Council to consider and light of
the announcements in this report staff
decided to delay that report mainly for
a couple of reasons but a significant
one being that through this through the
announcements
um made by the government three weeks
ago around waste minimization
there is a opportunity that exists now
through funding support that was
considerably narrower a month ago than
it is now
um
as a result of that staff believe that
it's would be remiss if we didn't take
that opportunity to have discussions
with the ministry of the environment
about what opportunities exist to offset
some of the costs we're looking at in
terms of our reintroduced recycling
program
and hopefully through that we can make
some further savings
that won't then fall on our rate payers
but therefore um
councils throughout the country to lift
the game around Recycling and hopefully
get back in as soon as possible a wider
recycling scheme for the residents of
the gore District so happy to take any
further questions or comments
thank you for that Jason did we have a
question for the report writer Council
McKenzie
Jason I'll just say no matter what
funding is available
Etc
we could possibly do some sort of
costing anyway
and find out like basic things like the
cost of the business say we need three
or something like that along those lines
subject to whatever funding is available
your thoughts please
thank you through worship yep absolutely
um we can provide costs but I think one
thing that we want to do is make sure
that those costs that we are providing
are accurate once we put numbers up
um they are out there for everybody and
we want to make sure that we're not
creating uh I guess or misleading not
only our communities but also elected
members in terms of what the actual
costs of reintroducing recycling are I
certainly want to make sure that the
information on providing two Council was
as accurate as accurate as it can be and
so the preference is to ensure that we
uh
look at all avenues to offset any costs
that we can for our communities around
the reintroduction of those and the only
other thing I just add to that is that
through these discussions there may be
something that we bring back to Council
in terms of the options report that they
have seen previously that is a is a
change uh I certainly already having had
discussions around it
um the proposal to look at
um
supporting home composting some of the
changes through the government
announcements May mean that that's not
the best road for us to go down in the
short term anymore so there's things
like that that we want to ensure that we
have a full package of what the uh
overall activity too of recycling costs
not just
um adding a third bin or
um you know what uh the cost is to get
back into a recycling South contract Etc
so we want to make sure that we've got
the full
um
full Gambit of those costs
thank you for that councilor Stringer
and then Council have out
through his worship to Jason
um
have we been given all the facts and
figures from government on what's
happening or is this a slow release of
information coming and is it likely to
change come October when we have an
election
through you worship I think you'll see
uh bullet point four
um and 2.3 of the report talks about new
and more comprehensive waste legislation
so that is still a a work in progress
the document that's been provided by the
government outside of the waste strategy
is a a guidance document so there still
will be more to come but as a report
outlines I don't think we're the
proposed direction from Council deviates
too much because of the announcements
but again we just want to make sure that
we take the opportunity to review those
and and make correct decisions at inform
our community
foreign
counter Stringer I don't think unlike
three Waters this particular strategy is
vulnerable to a change of government I
think my understanding both governments
would be wanting to see waste
minimization lowering our carbon
footprint so to me it makes a lot of
sense for both sides of the political
divide and therefore like unlike three
Waters where there could well be a
change this is probably the general
direction where the country will be
hitting in the future
the council does not operate in
isolation when it comes to waste we're
part of the wider network with waste
networking with the other territorials
and I I guess there's some overview
required by wastenet and I'm wearing my
hat now as the chairperson of of
wasteness in terms of there are some
economies of scale to be gained acting
as a region rather than acting
independently and there's also I guess
some synergies to be gained by actually
looking at our relationship with
adjoining councils and how we can work
in with them so I I guess the question
that I've got is that in terms of moving
forward
how does Jason see the relationship of
council working in with waste net of
actually progressing this in a timely
way
through your worship uh good question uh
three weeks since the announcements that
will be something we need to work
through alongside our other partners
Within wastenet
but again I think the the direction that
um
has been proposed and discussed around
the council table already aligns with
where the government's heading and that
was the purpose of the work that we'd
done uh with Dr Nikki bold last year in
terms of starting to re-establish and
reset we were heading with
um with waste minimization uh but we do
uh councilor Havel have an opportunity
to again look at how we work together
across the wastenet
um
the Western organization and again look
for any efficiencies that we can through
that that process to work together as
part of any refinement but yet that will
be part of the picture also but it
shouldn't be something that delays we
were trying to go as a council
thank you for that consoleduction
we worship I just think it's really good
to see that the government is putting
some funding into education because
consumer demand can actually drive some
of these businesses to think differently
and it will be good for our Council
having that support from from government
I feel
thank you counselor still doing
questions to Jason before again to
debate so for being procedural
um councilor Reed did you have a
question or I did thank you um for Jason
um two things one thing first thank you
again for your report again for your
report
um and also like to acknowledge the
members of the community who are quite
passionate recyclers who worked
alongside
um Dr bold and yourself to get us to
where we are the one question I would
have is regarding the government support
would that enable us to employ the waste
minimization officer or is that out of
um what they see is a positive move
through your worship
um
that that may be a stretch I'd suspect
that then every other Council across the
country might also be looking for some
funding support for positions or new
positions in particular but um certainly
look we have some meetings lined up with
Ministry for the environment
and then
oh
just wait for the lights to come back
excellent we have meetings lined up with
the ministry environment over the next
week both in terms of the waste
minimization fund and the glass
packaging Forum so
um hopefully we'll again we'll ensure we
discuss all avenues in terms of where
goals likely to be hitting with
Recycling and any opportunities we can
to minimize the cost of our brake pads
any further questions for Jason on this
report
I guess I just had one question the
adjacent um I recognized that this
legislation's only come out three weeks
ago and we're still processing it given
that the community is is you know
waiting for recycling to happen are we
able to give kind of a time frame as to
when those costs might come are they
part of the annual plan Workshop
upcoming or what's a time frame looking
like
through your worship I think uh
absolutely that's still the um at this
point
um that is the desire of staff is to
have that part of the annual plan uh
discussion which will be occurring over
the next month
um
and I guess the
the
question will be around the timing of
funding and when we can then press the
go button so it may mean
um that we have a delay because we
certainly won't don't want to
um
those funds are generally not able to be
extracted retrospectively
um so again hopefully by the time we we
come back and discuss this at the next
public meeting then we will have an idea
anyway of what a timeline May looks like
may look like which is again an
important consideration for Council
moving forward
thank you Jason and so there's a report
hopefully coming back to the the next
council meeting um regarding this
fantastic thank you for that
any further questions
no uh could I please get a mover that
the report be received and that the
council requests staff to further
investigate and understand the full
implications of the recent waste
announcements including any
opportunities to seek external funding
support for the options identified in
the ahina Consulting reports councilor
hovel is the Mover and the second it is
councilor McDonough
do we have any further debate
councilor mcphail
I know I sound as just really worship
it's more of a statement I sound like a
stuck record but and I think uh Jason
alluded to it
um to make sure that even though we've
got the government uh project or
strategy sitting here that it does
dovetail and with what we already have
existing in our small town and don't go
and stand on the little boys with the
big boys coming through we do have some
great recycling going on and I'd make
sure that um you know they are still
well and truly an aperture
thank you councilor and and to add a bit
more of a point that I think
um this the strategy gives us an
opportunity to do it do it right uh do
it once and do it right in line with
central government and and councils
around the company so I think we're in
countries right and I think we're in a
unique position to do that so
um I guess positives and and what some
councils may find negatives
was there any further comment
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
next we have the chief executive
appraisal committee uh
uh draft terms of reference to the chief
executive want to comment on this at all
no pretty straightforward you worship
thank you for that do we have any
questions for the report writer
councilor Stringer
through his worship um
I'm just monitoring a bit of clarity
around the procedural order here because
I understand it's come out of
stuff that was said in committee but we
haven't ratified those committee
minutes yet is this
does this have to go into committee and
then we read it like we ratified the
committee minutes and then
um then it can go through or can we can
we pass this without the Rosamund Spain
red Fighters trying to correct before we
do it sorry just nitpicking
uh extremely good question so not not
picking at all
um look the I guess if the council
collectively is satisfied that the
resolution that has been presented
before you is correct then as entitled
in to move on to approved in terms of
reference
do we have any further questions for the
tube executive
could I please have a mover that the
council endorse and adopt the attached
terms of reference of the Chiefs equal
appraisal committee
uh counselor read and seconded by
councilor Phillips I will now open the
floor for conversation or debate
did we have anyone who wants to speak
okay all pretty straightforward it seems
I just wanted to make the council aware
um that despite the recommendation
coming from the sorry the resolution
coming from the extraordinary meeting I
note that in accordance with skip
schedule seven part one Clause 31 1 of
The Local Government Act the council
removed the mayor from the chief
executive appraisal committee
um can't actually do that under Section
41 A5 of the Local Government Act 2002
it states that Amir is a member of each
Committee of a territorial Authority so
while I can be removed I'm still
technically a member of that committee
as I am a member for all of those
committees
say understood by councilors
counseling fail
I think uh in the best interests of what
we've got here is probably include that
in the minutes obviously it's something
that's been introduced and hasn't been
discussed with any of the chairs or
otherwise so note in the minutes we move
from forward from there unless there's
any debate around me
any debate
to get him if I can assist the Council
you worship that particular point was
traversed with a council's lawyer
verbally and confirmed that the mayor
can be removed from a committee but what
we can do if you wish we can get a
written opinion to confirm all that
position or otherwise
think that Chevy equinovious that would
be appreciated some some clarity on that
as my understanding is a section of the
ex takes precedence over a clause in the
schedule and that if Mayors could be
removed it would be written in that way
uh councilor mcphail
just to worship do you wish to remain on
the committee
by virtue of the ACT counselor I am
still on the committee
the question is we worship do you wish
to remain there or do what do you wish
to remove yourself
whether I wish to remove myself or stay
on I'm by virtue a member of that
committee regardless
any further comments
Council McFarlane yeah just through your
worship to the CEO obviously the request
would be for a written opinion then in
regard to that and uh I'd like to pass
that
pass emotion
from the floor and seek a second there
in regard to requesting a written
legal opinion in regard to you remaining
uh his worship remaining on the
committee uh
and uh
it's illegal
written opinion in regard to
the mere remaining on the committee for
the gorsio
so I might have to read back to me
I'll seek a second
uh we've got we've got a motion on the
table as it sets up I'm more than happy
for you to to put that motion next but
there is a motion on the table at the
moment so it's just discussing the
Motions on the table which is the that
the council endorse and adopt the terms
of reference of the chief education
appraisal committee
we've known for the discussion on that
do we want to put that motion
cool all those in favor please say aye
and against
motionless carry now there's a motion on
the floor from councilor mcphail which
is to seek a written legal advice
just through your worship just to
clarify the last motion that's been
passed has been passed indicating they
wish that you are removed
from the committee
by virtue of of the ACT I'm still on the
committee so
I I think I think it's worth we seek
legal advice for clarification on this
one um if counselors feel uncomfortable
otherwise it's just hearsay between us
yeah just
three worship it's just um a bit Askew
that we're actually voting on something
that can't occur
you've indicated that it can occur and
I'd seek some advice from the CEO is it
appropriate for us to vote on that
so you worship you're voting on a terms
of reference which has membership
and the membership as per the terms of
reference
does not include the mayor the mayor has
asserted that he believes he is still on
that committee by virtue of section 41A
um I've said that and I acknowledge that
there's 41A but also there's specific
Provisions for the council to remove
members of committees in the schedules
and I've covered that off verbally with
a council's public law lawyer
and so by approving this terms of
reference
it doesn't preclude
the it doesn't actually stop the
committee from moving forward what it
has created is a challenge about whether
the mayor should or can be removed from
the committee and we'll get that written
advice and come back to the next council
with clarity
thank you search who's your kid of
um just for clarification also and that
externally meeting where I was not
present you have already passed the
resolution under that that schedule so
I've already been removed but but my
argument was that I in fact can't be but
we will have the written statement to
clarify that
are you still happy to move that motion
that we get a written statement
yes thank you worship and CEO yeah I
would like to table the motion in regard
to a written legal opinion in relation
to the Clauses that you've cited around
uh the fact we cannot have you removed
from a standing committee
the Seeker secondary Canada secondary
cool who would you like to comment on it
at all councilor Phillips
uh no I just like to make clarification
so then we can make some comment things
I think if that is there any further
discussion on that motion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
number nine draft terms of reference for
the chief executive intermediary
uh did the YouTuber want to comment on
this draft no uh were there any
questions for the chief executive on
this
Council McKinsey
being a newbie I'd like to ask the
question reviews Etc in here CAO as
stated
the review may be costing more than what
any money could be saved Etc and some of
these things but I believe that we
actually need to see those figures for
Council to make decisions on tanks
how much does a review cost in any
particular thing sorry Council I think
you've jumped forward I apologize we're
on point nine draft terms of reference
for the chief executive apologies
do we have any questions for the chief
executive on the intermediary terms of
reference
councilor Dixon
thank you worship I just had one
question in the function of the
dedicated intermediary role
bullet point
bullet point six is authorizing the
approval of the chief Executives credit
card statements and annual leave
um just for protection for the person
authorizing is there a um another person
who authorizes before that so
someone from staff or management that
authorizes the payments I'm not
questioning it I'm just thinking to
protect the um intermediary role three
wishes these it comes ultimately the
payments and the verification of me is
from the general manager corporate
support
um so that but basically the rules
around credit card statements that
someone higher above you in the chain
should authorize your your credit card
statement
appreciate that thank you
so I just want to let you jump and
cancel it I just like some clarification
on that that point as well um if you
could so I've read the sensitive
expenditure policy uh 1.4 states in the
case of people in the very senior
positions of the principal approval by a
more senior person the one-up principle
should be applied to the maximum extent
in this case of the chief executive
approval is required by the Mia and vice
versa
um given that as in the policy I just
think that this thing contradicts
that policy so does it I'm I'm confused
on how this all works
thank you worship uh given that a
council resolution to point of
intermediary that just requires then
once this is goes through then we would
adjust the sense of expenditure policy
to reflect current practice
thank you
no uh councilor Stringer
oh yeah through his worship um the final
bullet points being authorized signatory
to legal documents including those
executed
because the council's common seal
um does the person taking that position
have any extra liabilities or
risks associated associated with them
taking that position
through your worship no and the
council's delegation policy talks about
underseal the mere or another elected
member and these documents invariably
are executed in line with a council
resolution to to enter into some sort of
transaction
any further questions for the chief
executive
all right
I before we move into debate and I call
for a second uh I
I guess I'd like to understand from
counselors what the intention of the
intermediary was
um there's points in here so one two and
and four which all seem reasonable as an
intermediary between communicate to help
Communications
um but points like three where
um the intermediary with a chair that
would attend the cheers role we've had a
chairs meeting there's there's other
elected members in the room I don't
understand why the intermediary would
need to be there
um as for providing a formal report I
guess I would be quite keen on getting
some clarification on what that report
would actually entail what we exactly
reporting on what would be expected from
that report
um I'm not too sure why the delegation
of authorizing slash approving the chief
executive credit card statements and
then you'll leave is being stripped from
me
um it is something that I've always
um
done on time and have never contested
credit card statements or annual leave
and 0.7 I also don't understand why the
authorized signatory is being stripped
off me so I guess some some
clarification as to why those are being
added in there and I guess
are they necessary in there or is it
more as an intermediary
Council I got on this was discussed at
the meeting and um it's more of an
intermediary effect and until the um we
have the commission or um
the people look into what the governance
of the council and what they recommend
so that's probably a two to three months
period
thank you Council any further comment
councilor Phillips I think you worship
it was it was to do with mainly about
making sure that that myself as a
counselor representing of the Raper of
of the district
that the functionality of council
continues and that's what it was all
about and until the review is taken
taken don't take anything in into it as
a grain of salt or or a slide on
yourself none whatsoever it's about the
functionality of council
that's the main objective
any further Council read
I think this also reflects the fact that
um the fact that the relationship is
broken down and as counselors it is our
duty to um
be responsible for the chief executives
well-being in this situation
Council Reed I I don't see how approving
legal documents on the council's behalf
or attending chairs meeting is is
relevant to the chief Executives
well-being
I think absolutely councilor Dixon I
just think you worship I was just
wondering if the chief executive would
like to respond to that
thank you yes I would because
conscious that the minutes the
discussion was held in committee uh but
the decisions were leaked and the
commitments or large chunks of it will
be in the public domain
so the legal the documents issue is that
unfortunately there's been prolonged
delays in having things signed off
and councils will be aware of that
so that's why I wanted an intermediate
tree to quickly be able to get things
signed off and keep things moving and
this Council has been
really
paralyzed with trying to make any sort
of progress over the last six months so
that's why in part
that particular that particular
provision was sought to keep things
moving in the council
and you know about the letters of
representation to finalize our annual
report that nearly resulted in having to
get a fresh approval from this Council
I don't think any document that I have
meant to assign his head to come back to
council to be science I I don't see the
need for it but that is the the
council's decision
uh as for having the intermediary attend
chairs meeting is is not a chair I I I'm
Barefoot as to why that's been included
councilor Havel thank you your worship
um with regard to the latest uh point
that you um raised
um the having the intermediary at the
cheers meeting was was seen at the time
as as part of that intermediary role
given that we've had our our first
chairs meeting
um and other senior staff have been
present I I guess the question to the
chief executive is on the basis of the
experience that we've had with with one
meeting does that still need to be
followed through as one of the duties of
of the intermediary
are you referring to the military
continuing to come to or go into the
cheers meetings yes look
Let's uh
that's a point of I think of um debate I
don't have a bottom line view on that I
think this is a new role and the idea
behind the intermediary coming to Cheers
meetings so that there was a guaranteed
method of feedback and an inclusion of
the intermediary and so the mayor and
cheers can can hear from from him on a
regular basis but on a personal boat
view I don't have a hard line view one
way or the other
yes
[Music]
can you hear me yes yeah
yeah thank you uh you wish through you
um
through the clarification around the
role of the intermediary and the
conversation that created or provided
the opportunity for intermediary folks
who were pleased just for more into
accounts
that it was huge accounts to and for the
council and it's ability to be a good
employer
so the general purpose of the
intermediary role in the functions
associated with
respect to the council being a good
employer for the chief Executives I
think was raised by councilor Reed so I
think it's in that light that as has
previously been discussed with you
um that was one of the the rationale for
an intermediary uh being appointed in
the functions of that intermediary to
achieve or assist that function
than being a good employee
thanks for that Rex
do we have any further comment Council
guard on
through the mere
um if the chief executive is not worried
about the intermediary meeting with the
chairs meeting we could
um delete that item
if people want these counselors are
agreed
Council mcphail and then Council over
it's just so you worship
um obviously uh as the nominated person
the recommendation the I'd I'd have no
issue not attending chairs meetings I've
been a chair understand what's discussed
there and I'm sure that in the Franken
um professional discussions I have with
you and the CEO I'd have any relevant
information given to me
uh one one other point I guess I just
wanted to ask councilors for
clarification at 7.2 that the
intermediary is required to meet with
both myself and the deputy mayor whereas
the intermediary is only just meeting
with the chief executive does the
nothing against Keith being there but
does he need to be there as as part of
the discussions I didn't think I need an
intermediary and also my deputy there to
receive information some of it may be
timely as well just just looking for
clarification nothing against
if I can help that sentence starts off
with um and or as required
so I would see that applying to me it
may well be some circumstances with the
intermediary things that he should talk
to both of us otherwise I'm quite
comfortable at his discretion as to
whether he's talking direct to you or or
jointly
thanks for that clarification counselor
is there any further conversation on the
terms of reference
could I please have a mover that the
council appoint counselor Richard
mcphail is the role of dedicated
intermediary between the chief executive
and the mayor and that the terms of
reference for the role of the dedicated
intermediary as uh attach be approved
councilor Reed seconded by
councilor Phillips
do we have any further debates
I think there's been several people who
have raised the point around the review
given that there is no reference to time
frames in these terms of reference are
we able to put I I don't want to
stricken Richard for the rest of his
term to have to be the intermediary are
we able to put a date around the
conclusion of the review as to when that
intermediary may may cease
that is the purpose of having bi-monthly
reporting from the intermediary and it
may well be that one of his reports
concludes with a recommendation that
that his role is no longer required so
rather than having a specific date there
or or trigger point
um was really setting it up so it was at
his discretion that was the intent
thank you for that clarification
councilor do we have any further comment
the councilor guard on do I have to put
a recommendation that the Jews
intermediary doesn't have to attend the
Junior's meeting
uh we can
we happy are we happy to withdraw the
motion and change it slightly the um the
Mover
we can do an amendment or we can
withdraw it and then just change it
slightly
did you want to withdraw it or should we
go through the amendment process
amendment process okay could I please
have a mover that we strike uh
Point number three uh councilor Guardian
seconded by councilor Stringer
uh do we have any conversation on the
amendment
no I will put the amendment all those in
favor please say aye
and against the amendment is carried so
the new
recommendation is that the council
appoint Richard mcfail is the
intermediary uh the terms of reference
of the deep of the dedicated
intermediate art as reported uh bar
striking Point number three
do we have any further conversation
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
the motion is carried thank you
councilors
number 10 Service delivery review with
the Chiefs that you'd like to speak to
the report
yeah this report
um governs the six yearly obligation for
the council to undertake a service
delivery review of its main activities
and this is a a provision in the local
government put in around about 2014 or
by the then government and to be honest
it hasn't spawned a lot of revolutional
change it has spawned a great Feeding
Frenzy for Consultants to come in and to
review the services and generally land
on the status quo but give you a 40 page
report and a decent invoice associated
with it when I say distant invoiced
we're talking
Thirty to forty thousand dollars a pop
I'm trying to avoid that
um because
it seems to me to be a a waste of time
however there are some parts that we do
need to do a review
um and roading is a specific provision
because of the Walker katahi um funding
component that comes with that Activity
three Waters a cinema report the
government has already made to uh made
up its mind and wants to reform that
particular activity and when you've had
a recent competitive
tendering process inside the last two
years you're exempt as well
um it's important to note that this
isn't a service level review
key point so that
if Collective members have a view that a
particular service could be slimmed down
reduced in some way to save money that's
a different type of conversation that
would come through your long-term plan
and Community engagement processes that
are conducted as part of that that
exercise so levels of service for all
activities will be the subject of a
separate Workshop during the course of
this this year so this is just really
about how you deliver a service and
whether it's in-house whether it's
Contracting a CCO
Etc and so my report really
um advances the the proposition that a
lot of these other services that we we
potentially have to do a a um a service
delivery review enjoy very high levels
of satisfaction through your annual
resident survey and therefore I don't
think if we I'd be very surprised if
someone said well you should be
contracting out your parks and reserves
for example or putting your library in a
trust or throwing Arts and Heritage into
a CCO the major steps obviously but
there seems to be
my perspective a good level of comfort
at the public particularly highly rate
those services so that's the that's the
way I've approached this to try and
minimize both the work at the cost
involved to to council to probably come
up with the same answer that that you've
currently got in terms of how these
services are delivered
thank you for that do we have any
questions for the chief executive
councilor McKinsey
uh through your worship you've kind of
answered the question that I had
it's it would be nice to see some
numbers
so you're saying a review for any one of
these particular sections would be
around thirty thousand dollars give or
take yep
okay
it will be
nice to see some figures there as I
admit I'm a newbie at this but just to
see some guideline of figures
um but that was one of my main questions
around thirty thousand dollars for a
review
to possibly come back and say well
you're doing it right anyway
but it would be nice to have that option
of looking or saying you know maybe we
could trim a little bit here or
in the long term that thirty thousand
dollars if it was found a way of saving
ten thousand dollars a year or something
possibly it will be worth it
that I'd like to chat then into the mix
please
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Reed did
you
yes thank you Mr Mia just a question
um Steve about the
um
rodent review and I know using your
crystal ball you probably won't it's one
of those do you think our
present level of subsidy will stay or do
you think it will decline given the fact
that waikato is
pretty lean at the moment with money
um three you worship yeah look the the
level of funding you get from Waka Qatar
he is quite a complex formula they use
and it's based around
um Capital values in in your District
it's also they have a floor so that no
one can fall through it so there's a
Bedrock minimum of funding that each
Council can be guaranteed
um so over the last 20 years uh waikatoi
funding has gravitated around 55 to 59
and I think it will it will be in that
area still walking guitar his funding is
stretched but it knows it has to
maintain what it's got but what you
might find is that they are particularly
challenged around new projects and who
knows what the effect of
cyclone Gabrielle will have in regard to
its funding and then of course you've
got the the ongoing effect of the
electrification of vehicles and and
reducing revenue streams but in the
immediate future I'd be surprised if
it's uh outside that 55 or 59 window
scene
cancel the Stringer
oh thank you through his worship
um do we need to be using consultants
for this is there any way we can do it
in-house like over six years
if we put one off a year and had someone
dedicated to looking at in the house
through your worship yes
um very hard two things one is that it's
quite a demanding process that the ACT
requires
some councils can do it in-house when
they've got policy endless with
experience
a lot of councils tend to farm it out
because they can believe they believe
they're getting a degree of objectivity
into their their thinking
um could we do it one one a year the
answer would be yes but you'd need to
start kind of starting from this year to
work your way through the activities so
that every six years you've actually
ticked off each activity we've just put
this to sleep for six years suddenly
2023 has come around and we need to
conduct all these reviews this year if
we choose to do so
any further questions
because I had one uh the last time this
review came up to be done uh were
Consultants uh contracted then or was it
a similar process of
um just basically looking to throw and
saying that that we don't need to be
reviewed
uh no there were Consultants used for
roading
three Waters and I'm pretty sure there's
one other activity that was used but
some of these were the the subject of
look we don't need to go there we're
happy with what we've got and we didn't
we didn't actually
um commission reports but the ones we
did off memory were a reasonably sized
fee at the end of it and the important
thing was that they were just
recommending the status status quo in my
personal view there wasn't a lot of
benefit deriving gear from in Council
McKenzie's point about maybe it might
find some savings
again that's more like Service delivery
and the the model of section 17A really
steers you down a pathway of comparing
different methods of delivering a
service so for example in-house versus
CCO versus a shared service versus
Contracting out for example
so just for clarification there are a
number of these recommendations here
that we would be signing up for not
having done a proper review and almost
12 years
that's correct
yes that's correct
um although Arts and Heritage has had
the subject of as I said my report uh
memorandum of understanding that have
been reviewed with the various trusts
that operate in that Precinct
um
building control is the subject of a
two-yearly accreditation process which
talks about or analyzes how that service
is delivered
but it's up to council if a council
really wants to see a review done we can
do it
do we have any further
comments uh Council Phillips thank you
worship sitting on the table as a
counselor I have more than confident
with the abilities of the staff in
what's progressed to me as a counselor
on what they do on a day-to-day basis
and I believe that we are definitely in
a good a good ship in the fact is that
we have our in-house staff who have been
with us for quite a long time not only
management managerial staff but also on
the ground staff
um debt is an indelible knowledge that
this District needs to keep and I
believe if we went down the contract
rule position as many Council councils
around the New Zealand will tell you
beard in your in your own mind it'll
cost you a lot of money in the end
because everything that they do will
cost you money and uh yeah I'm more than
more than happy
um with what's what's happened over the
last six years and and just congratulate
the staff on the continued service to us
thank you for that counselor councilor
McNabb
I concur with councilor Phillips we're a
very small Council we've got staff that
are here dedicated and parks and
reserves whether we think the service
the level of service is a discussion for
for another for another format so we're
just looking at how we deliver it
whether it's contracted out so I'm quite
comfortable in the way we do things and
I do not want to spend money on
Consultants so I'm very much in favor of
the recommendation
thank you
thank you councilor
any further comment
I guess I just wanted to circulate with
counselors I I appreciate that uh
conversation around the table is that we
we don't want to spend the money
um right now and we have to do this this
year there was a mention of rolling
reviews after that though
um and whether there would be an
appetite from councilors of lessening
the burden so we don't get to six years
in in six years time and we're looking
steering down the barrel of 18 years
without a review
oh have I done my message right
yes 18 years without a review Council
herbal
I do not support a revolving review on
the matters that are dealt with in this
report
to quickly go through them three Waters
and planning Services
aren't required to be reviewed because
of the these legislative changes and
planning Services were subject to
competitive tender two years ago
of of the other ones roading is underway
and that's quite appropriate and it's a
statutory requirement from the roading
authorities when you look at the other
ones on the list parks and reserves can
you imagine the um issues that we would
have if it was contracted out
um by having it in-house Council has
total control over what is done and what
the cost is and it would concern me if
we went through an exercise of of even
um approaching
um the spending type of money the chief
Executives talking about to do it for
that similarly for Arts and Heritage it
has been through a number of Financial
reviews in the like in recent years and
I can't see any benefit similarly I
imagine there would be a significant
public outcry if this Council was
wanting to go into some sort of joint
Arrangement or contract out our library
Services they're in the building next
door to us they're an integral part of
what happens and I I see no benefit of
that
Aquatics and the me MLT Event Center has
a particular set of circumstances
applying to a present that requires the
overview of council for financial
reasons that I do not believe would be
achievable through any other means other
than the council retaining full control
and there's no to building control goes
for a two-yearly review so I'm quite
comfortable with the recommendation that
is sitting in the report and I'm happy
to move the recommendations that are
there as written
think of that before up you would like
to Second counselor or okay would you
like to speak to the motion again as a
secondary I don't know
I I just wanted clarification around
Council is that the consultant is for
the review the the Departments aren't
we're not handing them over to
Consultants
we we got that it's correct because the
it's written in the report under Section
17A the local government
uh
uh it's a review of the cost
effectiveness of the current
Arrangements
so it's whether we're doing so even if
it's in a house it's whether we're being
cost effective in our in our
Arrangements
we
understand that councilor Stringer
so does that highlight areas where we're
under investing as well and okay
no it's primarily from from my
understanding and correct me if I'm
wrong around the whether we are
performing the service with a with a
cost effective lens over it so whether
we are performing those services to to
the most cost effective way that we
possibly can cancel Australia through
his worship do we have to adopt anything
else that reveals the review just put
towards us we accept it and go well we
like the way things are and carry on
we we don't have to the report comes
back and as the chief executive very
rightly pointed out it's it's can be
common that it comes back status quo
um my argument was just that it's been a
very long time since we've had that
review so for it to come back status quo
but I don't know would would be a shock
to me but that's just my my humble
opinion
are there any other comments captured
mcfire
it's just true you worship uh you refer
to a review of 12 to 16 years ago or 12
years ago do we know what it actually
came back as
across do we have major issues
uh three years no not a law all reports
were done so far have just said pretty
much the current method of Service
delivery which is a notable bias towards
in-house is the way to go and I do know
that over the years you know Parks
reserves to quote councilor hovels
example of other Consultants working in
this field say you've got the right
model and you can see it in in your
townships and communities and it's a
high level of finish in the and the care
and the in the high regard that your
staff have for their their working
environment it shows through so no
there's been no changes that I can
recall that have come out of this this
this process
um the the original mover of the of the
legislative provision the government of
the day might be disappointed but that's
the reality
um and also you it's changing the way in
which you deliver a service
is a big step and does involve you know
cost risk as well
um and I'm reminded of just recently of
a you know of a a council not far from
here almost pulling out an SOS call to
assist with a contract that's just not
working for them so
um we've that's over the years this
Council has not gone down the
Contracting path and decide not to
scratch that itch but overall reports
that we have received of
um you know actually
endorsed the status quo
and for those who were interested in
rolling and that's one where we do have
a contractor service and often it gets
complaints about the the services
rendered not so much in more recent
times but that's an example where once
you lose an element of control it's very
hard to rest it back
cancellation thank you worship I feel
very confident in the staff managing
this and I think
um really we don't want to go putting
extra pressures on people and doing
reviews at this time and it is a cost
and I I think we have to be wary of that
as well with inflation costs and all the
other costs coming upon us
we're seeking the motion and I stick
into motion
oh
and just the clarification there's no
appetite to in State uh starting to
there's there's five different ones that
could be starting that review so we
don't get caught in this situation in
six years time and there's there's no
appetite to that conversation
so we're we're signing up to quite a
long time without any review counselor
Phillips
I think it was as I said before
I feel confident in the fact that as a
counselor sitting in around this table
that what gets presented to me is is Top
Line stuff and
the confidence I have in the staff to do
the do the job for me
and is the chief executive said the
reviews of the most common things that
happen are
the roading and we had a review not
really long ago about the cemeteries and
we got theirs tidied up
um and so on so if if there is little
weak tweaks that need to be done it's
brought To Us by staff and we can carry
them up but can you imagine if we had
dealings with the contractor
what we'd be dealing with and I think um
yeah it's a lot more difficult and I and
I feel confident that what we're doing
is is okay
thank you councilor is there any further
conversation
councilary I'm very comfortable with
both Council hotel and councilor Dixon's
motion and second and and also the
reinforcement of our staff
thank you Council for clarification it
was moved by Council hovel and seconded
by councilor Max and now any further
conversation that's right counselor
no I will put the motion which
is would the councilors it's quite quite
long so I'll just put the motion um all
those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
thank you councilors uh local government
New Zealand conference 2023 uh seems
pretty straightforward would you like to
comment on this at all no
uh do we have a volunteer who would like
to come with me to the conference
oh
you you wish it is from the 26th to the
28th of July so Wednesday the 26th to
the 28th of July councilor Phillips I'm
not volunteering as such but um it is a
good opportunity for any new councilors
that wish to go to
um
meet and greet other councilors see what
other councils do listen and learn and
it's a really good opportunity so if you
can spare the time to take that
opportunity go please go
if there's no counselors throwing up
their hands I just see the community
board cheer has thrown up hers
to the provision state that we can take
a community board chair or
that's purely
purely it's purely uh council discretion
tuition
would there be a nomination in that
capacity because councilors are
comfortable with that
councilor Regis sorry nothing about the
chair but given that councilor hovel is
our in his first term as Deputy Mia if
he would be willing to go in that
situation I think that would be a really
good
learning curve for Hunter
you know the
um
of of attended a a couple of the The
Zone meetings and and contact with other
Mayors and I saw it as an opportunity
um particularly for one of the the new
councilors
um to to have learnings from it there's
not many opportunities when the chair of
the community board can attend things
and I'm I think it'd be an excellent
idea for her to go
um she would probably get um as much as
anyone else
would you like to put a nominations
warden in that capacity does it require
a number I think it's a sigh I think
it's just recommendation yeah that's
fine counselor uh
I was just uh agreeing with the
commentary regarding that if we haven't
got a a counselor that was prepared to
attend but just also with reference to
the previous intermediary role as long
as we're sufficient that we can uh XCX
and that without the intermediary going
um that would be quite uh good to see
and I'd actually recommend that the uh
that that the chair chairperson of the
community board I definitely recommend
that
I'm sure we can have that conversation
as part of the buying new reports as
well that come to council
uh so the recommendation on the table if
we have a mover uh would be that the
council delegation to attend the 2023
local government New Zealand conference
in Christchurch
compromise others worship the mayor the
chief executive and the community board
chair
do we have a mover for that I'm happy to
move councilor mcphail and a second
councilor next to now do we have any
further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
number 12 James [__] community center
and library development project update
with the Chiefs that you've liked to
comment on this report
um thanks you worship the project as we
know obviously now is uh completed uh
there's obviously probably a few loose
Financial ends to come through but the
um big I guess important news from the
council's perspective is that the
forecast final cost Remains the Same as
it was last month
and there's still a little bit of
contingency to deal with any last minute
Loose Ends so overall the project has
gone very very well
thank you for that do we have any
comment from councilors
nope I well uh the recommendations that
report they receive can I get a mover
counselor stranger and the second
accounts for their guard iron
further comments
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
number 13 Great South draft statement of
intent would the choose it could have or
also Anne if she feels the need brought
to comment on this report
I think so we should I think mullet uh
Ann who's been waiting patiently in the
wings
um to speak to this
um
obviously the report is a why while
written by me has been
um also incorporate some of the thoughts
that Anne had when she read the document
as well
our relationship with great South is
it's in very good condition we have an
excellent relationship with them
um we are a very small funder as in
comparison to the other councils and the
discretionary money is sitting at sixty
thousand dollars just to give you an
example in the last Financial year or
The Current financial year we
um
worked with great South to do the fly
fishing strategy they also funded for us
the amendable railway project a
strategic piece of work which was done
to enable government government funding
they've continued to provide support for
events and work with not only our
tourism team but our tourism operators
and some of them have had a fairly
rugged time the last couple of years
um in discussions around going forward
there in closing the gaps program
there's quite a
will with some of our big employers to
work together and the attraction
attraction and retention Market space
and that is a piece of work that great
South are intending doing and we have
flagged with them that we do want a a
bit of a Centric approach because we
believe that just trying to sell
Southland will not actually help us to
the level in bringing people to gore
we have a strong relationship with the
regional business partners program and
with it and without going into the
detail but there's a whole lot of things
on offer to businesses and we've made
our offices available here to Great
South's team to come and meet with
businesses and now that the new library
is available they're going to base
themselves Wrigley out of the library
both for drop-ins and regular
appointments
so the figures that is the Baseline
funding is 150k plus there's actually
two years inflation so the figure of
furthest coming year is going to be
sitting around 156
000 plus the 60k
um I'm happy to answer any questions I
mean there's so many bits and pieces of
work that my team is doing with great
South and The Wider teams of council
um
yeah so if you've got questions I'm
happy to answer them
thank you for that and I know you put a
lot of hard work into
um into this uh contract in particular
uh do we have any questions for Anne
Council guard on
just through the mirror um and we're as
a small Township in waikeka book Rail
and Mandeville very interested in
getting fiber from those areas extended
in their communities and it's been quite
a stumbling block it's something we need
to really push for
just um
that uh the chief executive from Great
South and your strategic manager Steve
Kenny we're here in Gore for the energy
strategy and after that meeting I spoke
to them again about the digital work
they've been doing there is a report
that they're going to release in two
weeks time that is going to give us a
lot more insights to places and spaces
and we have flags that both the chief
executive and I felt that their comments
and the
documents perhaps needed to be reviewed
and strengthened and so we're definitely
flagging in I believe Southland district
is flagging that that's a key piece of
work because there's a lot of people in
our district especially in the farming
community that still don't have
connectivity
just the economy is those schools
country schools have got it and it's
just a matter of getting their
connection into the system at a
reasonable price
thanks for that counselor councilor
Dixon thank you Russia
um just for you to Ian
I've noted that um there's nothing about
climate change or carbon neutral it's a
future but it is is is that being left
to environment Southland to take care of
um but are these strategies through
Great South for each province on this
uh they're still working in that space
and the energy strategy definitely
covers off
decarbonization so they're definitely
still in that space and I think part of
the
the holding pattern wherein is waiting
for Beyond 2025 to come out and they'll
be recommendations within that document
as well so both myself and other members
of the team
um Jason has also been sitting on some
of the work streams around Beyond 2025
so that work hasn't disappeared yeah
councilor Reed
thank you Mr Mayor um just Ian for you a
question around the attraction and
retention of people to the district I
mean currently we've got 11 of
Southlands population in 2019 that were
actually uh from a very wide diverse
intake of immigrants and I know that
it's probably increased since then but
the one thing I have noticed over time
working with great South is that Gore
is often worked around
um so I just wonder if if you were able
to
um
give me any clarification around that
but going forward
I guess
that's why we're in discussions right
now about making sure that there is a
piece of work that's goalcentric because
if we just go to the market and tell a
Southland story further up the country
it's not necessarily going to give the
results for our really big employers and
our really big employees have flagged
that they really want to come to the
table and work with the closing the gaps
team on this
um and there's quite a diverse range of
skills that they're looking for but it
also covers off when we do get people
that come here making sure like through
our welcoming communities program that
we've got the services to wrap around if
they're immigrants it's actually making
sure that it's easy to open a bank
account all of the things that actually
become a real barrier and I mean we Mark
and I we actually have dealt with things
that some cases in the last few weeks
where people have come and not had such
a good experience and then we're at risk
of losing them so there's a lot of work
needs done in that space but definitely
we're asking for some gore-centric Focus
perfect thank you and I take on board
what you're saying about working with
the immigrants because quite often
the other side of the coin they come
they feel
um not unwelcome but they're out of
their depth that Community contracts and
then it's harder for the next lot of
people that come into so I think it's a
very important part of work that you and
Mark are both doing thank you
thank you for that counselor councilor
uh
industry you worship for n Obviously
good work
um obviously aware of some other
projects we've done over the years do
you think we sufficiently fund it do you
think the money we put in we get the
best bag for our buck
are you asking about our team are we
sufficiently budget or are you asking
you've got a great sale
and you can take it either way if you
like I think for the money we put into
Great South
um I would say we've got more than our
Shia
and I believe the reason we've got more
than Ash here is because we work very
closely with them and we really try to
support when they want to do something
whether it's with businesses here or
bring programs to gore and we're very
specific about what we ask them to bring
in its needs based it's not just rolling
out things because they're part of a
package
so yeah I think that we do very well for
the amount of money we're putting into
Great South
all right thank you and for your honest
answer it's good to hear
thank you for that counselor and and I
guess to build on that as well just
looking at the contract funding we only
put in Sixty thousand dollars compared
to the other two big funders of six
hundred thousand dollars so so we do get
quite a good bang for our buck um on on
this deal
do we have any further comment
sure
so the recommendation is that the
council endorsed the draft statement of
intent for the Great South full Great
South in regard to the 2023-2024 with
the year with the addition of a more
personal wording in relation to the
digital connectivity and that the
council note that the community surge
manager will be working with great sales
to develop particular initiatives that
will benefit the gore District directly
do I have a move at Council Dixon
seconded by councilor Paul mcphail any
further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye and against the motion is
carried
thank you councilors uh that brings us
to the end of the public part of the
meeting we are going to have a 15-minute
break